[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be dressing the question what
happened to Harry Potter's grandparents
how did they die James and Lily Potter
were murdered by Voldemort at the very
young age of 21 the film sort of painted
a different picture in that the actors
portraying them are seemingly much older
than this I think that when most people
find out just how young James and Lily
actually were they're usually a bit
surprised
so if James and Lily were only 21 it
should be very safe to assume that some
of Harry's grandparents would still be
alive JK Rowling has stated and we've
seen that witches and wizards can live
for a very long time much longer than a
usual human so it always seemed unusual
that Harry wouldn't have a single
grandparent after all he should have
four let's start with Lily's parents
they're Evans the books have stated that
both of Lily's parents died normal
Michael deaths without going into any
detail we know that they both died
sometime between 1971 and 1980 one
because in 1971 they so Lily after
Hogwarts at platform nine and
three-quarters and in 1981
Lily was murdered we know them to be
dead at this point it's unusual that
they would have died in this time frame
and I'm really not sure what constitutes
a normal muggle death it definitely is
an old age because they would have been
far too young so if it wasn't old age
what's a normal death cancer heart
attack it's really hard to say provided
that all of the information we have on
their deaths groups them together and
that they were so young I suspect some
foul play Lily and James Potter were
both very outgoing witches and wizards
during the order of the Phoenix and
actively participating in the fight
against evil
this meant that they were very much on
the radar of Voldemort and the Death
Eaters in the Harry Potter films we've
seen so many instances of Death Eaters
terrorizing muggle London and attacking
muggles so why would the list parents be
an exception my theory is that because
Lily was so prominent in the fight
against evil having defied Voldemort
three times she made her family a target
because her parents were both muggles
they would have had no means of
defending themselves and the Death
Eaters could have this
to them and ended their lives instantly
in a deleted scene from Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows harry approaches
petunia and sister following reference
to the Death Eaters they'll torture you
if they think for a moment that you know
where I'm going they'll stop at nothing
to which she responds you think I don't
know what they're capable of to me this
implies that petunia knows more about
the Wizarding World and previously
implied
she's initially painted as a little bit
ignorant towards everything going on but
really I think that she knows exactly
what's happening because she's
experienced it before was not only Lily
but her parents as well this would also
explain her adamant hatred of everything
magical so that's my theory
this of course contradicts what JK
Rowling has said so take from it what
you will but I just found myself unhappy
with her original answer okay moving on
to James's parents James's parents were
three menthe and Euphemia Potter
they were both pure blood witches and
wizards that came from affluence FLE
Mundt was the ancestor of Lyn Fred of
Stinchcomb who invented an extensive
number of potions FLE want himself was
also an avid potion maker and created
the sleek Easy's hair potion which
quadrupled the family's cold
unlike Lily's mother Euphemia became
pregnant with James much later in her
life and gave birth to him in March 1960
while their deaths were not particularly
interesting there was a little bit more
information that has been provided in my
last video I discussed all of the
Wizarding diseases epidemics and
ailments one in particular
dragon pox was the cause of both of
their deaths dragon pox is a contagious
disease occurring in wizards and witches
that can be fatal it's similar nature to
the muggle chickenpox it leaves a little
pock marks on the skin and can result in
the lasting greenish tinge in some cases
it can resolve in green and purple rash
between the toes and sparks that come
out of the nostrils or when the patient
sneezes it sort of makes sense they
would have both died from this because
they were vulnerable and old the disease
was very contagious perhaps because of
their age they weren't able to properly
fight the disease similar to the way
that the chickenpox virus intensifies
and develops as shingles in adults I
don't have a theory for how they died
because I'm satisfied with the
explanation given however I would have
loved to have seen or heard more about
these characters in the books and films
and that concludes the video I hope you
guys enjoyed it what do you think of my
first Theory make sense or out of line
for questioning what Rowling has stated
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]